Oh help stir aren't you help me by  chance you see I've got this big hat I  like to wear when I dance that's a  really big hat why thank you printed  from the moment that I move all my  troubles begin we got a word for  troubles and the word is bugs they're  the pesky little problems that nobody  loves more I think I'll show you on the  dance floor I've got a big hat I've got  a big dance gotta move my head gotta  move my legs do it helps turn everybody  see back every time I do my des I'm  always losing my hat a hat that won't  stay there's a problem for sure can  anybody think of something that will  keep it secure tape it huh that's what I  said out of your head here's a little  piece of tape from the kitchen drawer  now we'll see you I've got a big hat  I've got a big dance gotta move my hair  gotta move my hands do it do it  ah the tape wasn't strong enough  strap it wrap it to your chin will keep  the strap from the so we'll see you on  the big  [Music]  you